what he said about Tick Tock was
freaking unborn I leave that [ __ ] up too
it's crazy
that's right
crazy I was right though
crazy I was right
hey it just made sense to me in the
moment like I was like man if I had a
social media company this is what I'm
sure America does it's like we got
Facebook Instagram so we could like feed
the algorithm in these other countries
anything we want and I assume what we do
we are doing it with movie and TV shows
for years it's like we're sending out
all our cool [ __ ] and then everybody in
other countries like I want to be a
cowboy I want to be a cool guy I want to
do this stuff it literally ended the
Cold War blue jeans and Rocky was it is
that what it was literally yeah I
thought they ran out of money no that's
part of it because they were spending it
all on Bluetooth
not the space right no no it was Levi's
but no that culture culture I mean
that's every part of that yeah well if
China
I want to hear it yeah but yeah
basically like yo China controls the
algorithm and they're showing different
[ __ ] to the kids out there than they are
over here they could get us into this
dumb [ __ ] everybody's twerking making
stupid videos where in China they're
doing [ __ ] math problems and
Engineering
but it's so [ __ ] true yeah I put that
[ __ ] out there and I repost it and I was
like man I was on one with this one but
that's what happens with jokes like
sometimes they make sense in your head
and you're like let me just throw it out
there and see and um and then I got on a
[ __ ] safe but people in the state
department put it that way got back to
me and they were like yeah that's that's
that's kind of what it is no [ __ ] so
you're now on the inside with State no
no they're not talking to me directly oh
okay
you're getting the same status but I
don't want to be involved you nailed
look I think about the American kids
here are doing they're doing the [ __ ]
uh tide pod challenge you know like
myself on fire and like what the [ __ ]
are you doing bro like and the kids are
you doing it over there you can't do
[ __ ] they're not watching [ __ ] just yeah
science yeah that's all you're watching
our tick tocks are fire though like that
is pretty dope watching a kid like
themselves on fire that's that's fun bro
if you really want to think about that's
who did that first wasn't that like
Tibet or some [ __ ] like was it Tibetan
guy the monks viral Tick Tock [ __ ] was
fine that was like man somebody tape
this [ __ ] PVD you you've got strong
opinions on what we should do with Tick
Tock at this point you did a whole case
study about you're doing videos on
Instagram that get literally millions of
views get rich and on Tick Tock you're
getting like five views it's like
clearly something's up this is this is
what's gonna happen I mean the tick
tock's got a lifespan they're not going
to be around forever tick tock's got a
lifespan you got a year two years one
Republican president away from Tick Tock
being banned in America and you're gonna
be the next Vine and some people who are
not ready for it they're not going to be
adjusting it's already done yeah you
think so yeah YouTube shorts yeah that's
the beautiful thing about like about uh
This is Gonna sound [ __ ] up but kind
of like when like government and uh
social media companies are in bed with
each other I mean you know the game
probably better than anybody but I would
assume once your company gets big enough
the government goes hey now we work
together
and then you go okay it's kind of like a
mafia yeah
but it's like you've reached escape
velocity and now we work together and so
with YouTube shorts It's the exact same
thing as Tick Tock if you look at it
right only it has way more data and way
more American data you're talking about
YouTube which is Google right these are
the numbered one and two search engines
in the world there's no way that you
would prefer to be on Tick Tock than you
would be on YouTube well brother think
about it in America you know what's the
Chinese TV station that we all watch MTV
there's no Chinese media here it's
because we don't want our kids or our
civilization being indoctrinated by CCP
thoughts yeah but they averted that
through social media through Tick Tock
yeah so at some point who owns Tick Tock
uh bite dance who's owned by the CCP
yeah at some point and this is one of
the things Trump was I got credit for
yeah we need to re-look into this yeah
I'm sure that we're not getting more
into it now bro we don't need it but do
you guys hear so I think it was
yesterday the South Dakota governor um
Christy gnome she banned it from every
agency state agency none of y'all could
use tick tock at all it's all off their
phones
so the South Dakota governor uh Norm she
spoke uh she I think she's pretty isn't
she said it's off our networks it's
blocked off of our servers any state
employee anybody who contacts in the
state of South Dakota [ __ ] on you period
good foreign so with all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of value tame men it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hats
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]